до референдуму за вийшов з-під рук
відбилися від 2000 optima кита цінних нам
ці білборді багато лаку сміття вдома ви на
по батчата профіль нікита противники
асоціації україн-ес
агітують віртуально в інтернеті права
людини демократії та верховенства закону
я всі інші в українських умовах та єху
європе оленберг гвинт відразу мені своїм
фондом на мага і типу якщо це через
комікси
він уже забрали багата тисяч не парячись
їду з вас міражах ніж молодший ти в
нідерланди проти ступу України та й
скажи арьєн і ціни на stream ag заарештують
себе противники асоціації даний стенд
ми на мага і ми сюди пункти людям
зрозуміє ще референдум не про
розширення с а проспіт протисвербіжним з
наших сусідів ми з подеваем ася щілина у
дена і якби часом не знають у чому у
тему коміксі написано у геїв та лесбіянок
в Україні та майрі в них прав і светри
sexual а ми там і голосую проти і
покарай то мою голосую за те-де ми зможемо
змінити п.м.
але тим лгбт у балансі столиці мусабаєва
одно хочу показати а я до ситуації в них
не краї не українці зняли фільм сім'я la
твій тушонку один з учасників проекту
we come грою раз побачити про свої жити
адже перші особи тесті голодник
подивиться і вимкне як символ віддати
подавайте і ви мкм та звук to win можна
подумати шукає всіх баланс до програма
про голландських розуму сексуальних включити
звук якось і не шамова виглядає ряд
показую я ми всі схожі тому що ми всі
схожі доступні аспект економічний
противники асоціації при до ночі євразії
та реалізації до нідерландів з України
зроблені душі в робочу силу при клініці
секція організації плями за ви
проголосуєте за нідерланди здаються
доглядових 1 для бізнесу javid краї ринок
україни пульти що криз каїві
організацію нарощувала його та лазербік
пробуємо його слідів їм ще в Україні
волоки проблеми і їх не ви вирішите за
один день для нас важливого щоб нове
покоління українці століття хочеш змінити
україну на касі отримала всю необхідну
Петренко
в Європі щур рушників і ми знаходимо
ще один щур
поряд з нашим вихідним та кордонами ось
стане нижчою перед референдумом
роз'яснено роботу видається і в
університетах у формі дебаті ланка
застанемо досвід його ним іміджі половина
молодих балансі до 34 років дасин та
знає про референдум запланований
нашого stack with me